I want to be a yo-yo man he cried make
me a yo-yo man
but the yo-yo master did not answer he
just kept on going
what's up my fellow yo-yo bros that's
right
we still out here floor gang imagine
being a ceiling cringe
you can't Joe you're from the ceiling
everyone can tell me everyone knows that
now the clip I just showed you
it's from yo-yo man 1988 a classic this
was the peak of yo-yoing is it yo yo yo
yo I never get it right now I'm somewhat
of a yo-yo expert like I know my stuff
ok I know my stuff but I never taken my
yo-yo to the next level so now that
we're Florida gang floor gang smash like
if your floor gang by the way let's
watch this video from 1988 and see what
we can learn about the art of yo-yo
[Music]
we haven't even started and I already
feel like my depression has been cured
Thank You codec just say no oh just say
yo a gay kid you're gonna come into my
bed
yo hell yo a gay you want some good yo
give it a what are they gonna say with
that kids I guess they're going for hey
don't do drugs do we do yo yo and I get
it and I agree with that sentiment
that's the kind of stuff that's gonna
take the human race to the next level
alien species will study us and say you
know what the breaking point was really
the invention of the yo yo sorry I'm
making too many jokes do we need to just
get started that's impossible
oh my god that's actually cool can I be
that good if I'm able is that a place
just say yo that was a that was a good
read
you realize nothing will ever be cool s
the 80s I mean the straps their shirts
the ramp oh my god it's right this is
what this is what we now know the cycle
of trends it's basically every 20 years
everything comes back the glasses the
yo-yo we're all we made a full circle hi
I'm dick smothers but wait what was it
they hi I'm dick smothers but that is a
weird name is it me or is that a weird
that's a weird name right it's a picture
of me when I was just a little boy now
I've grown up to be the voice of yo I'm
here to tell you how my brother Tom
after many years of searching and long
hours of practice became the yo-yo man
and how uten that's literally the yes
meme right there
with yo-yo in it oh my god how before
time with this this is the prophecy it's
all been said before man and how you too
can attain that lofty state of young we
started out with a normal family life
with mom Tom and me and we had a healthy
and happy childhood
that is until Tom talked me into joining
the army excuse me what what happened to
his dad is well I'm why do I know this
after an honorable discharge Tom and I
went off and pursued the truth of life
which ultimately led us to the state of
yo
goddamn the graphics man that's cool are
we gonna get some history now nice I
like how they're already laughing when
I'm laughing too bad for different
reasons okay
people love it he's got a cello is that
a cello yeah sure it's T'Challa why does
he have a cello that's hilarious no one
knows for sure but according to the yo
yo man that's a phase isn't it that's
not a cello as in I'm Swedish I don't
know all the instrument in English I'm
sorry the evolution of the yo yo first
began a long long time ago when a man
was caught observing a frog he looked at
that frog he noticed the frog had a very
unusual tongue sleepy now
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
god the live track makes us so obnoxious
I hate it
have you ever tried to rewatch friends I
know it's unnatural exam I can't stand
it I love friends I'd the laugh track is
so annoying it kills me oh my god
spiders I thought I was gonna be
studying the yo I want to learn about
the yo-yo I need to get yo-yo points
it's important never tame the yo-yo
directly at anybody now come on plenty
of room for tricks because you never
they net clearly never heard of terraria
am i right gamers get ahead in life
routine we've all been doing it wrong
cold showers waking up early meditating
working out
no yo-yo you just got a yo-yo that's the
way to do it how did it become a
millionaire and so successful what is
his secret
what in the world this is so confusing
the watch yes the diner lane your your
tricks notice that each trick has its
own color that's so that when you want
to refer to a particular trick for
review just fast forward your VCR until
you see the flashing color of your
choice press play and you're ready to go
the sleeper I never done this this is my
first time I'll try the tricks okay
release yo-yo in the sleeper position
spinning at the bottom of the string at
a high rate of speed
now the yo-yo master has his hand up in
the air the arm you don't have to do it
like that you can if you want but it's
not necessary now see the finger their
little target the finger yo-yo back up
to the palm of the hand how do you know
you man why don't you try it that's not
a trick that's not a trick
thirty-year-old man yo-yo should have
invested in yo-yo stocks before this I
remember when I was a kid
yo-yo was a fad in school it was really
fun actually I really enjoyed it
Hey look at that I did the sleeper yeah
alright that's one down get out of here
alright walk the diode Ernie now come on
pieces to the side and across them I
can't be walk the dog I'll do it but you
will be ok what if I
I'll do it on my plate what's good break
away break away is a little different
from the other tricks in that the
releases to the side and across the body
Jesus Christ I didn't mean to yo dude if
only my eyes just saw this okay over the
falls over the falls is a pretty fancy
trick
what fling the yo-yo straight out and
back over your wrist straight down and
back up to the pommel oh my god it's
okay what's good what's good they said I
will never be yo-yo easy I just break my
yo-yo I remember breaking my friends
Jojo and he made me you mean he made me
pay him back and I didn't do it so he
told his mom it's empty so then my mom
had to paint not me epic why is it fun
why am I having fun around the world so
the yo-yo mans ah that's easy because it
best illustrates his philosophy of life
for thinks of us as the yo-yo in the
palm of the hand and as we live life we
go out into the world spinning around
and around seeing new places and making
yo-yo and philosophy to things I would
never thought would come together but
here we are I got it watch this gamers
dude I got it
ah Jesus this is the video that's gonna
take oh god I forgot to do the thing
like PewDiePie yeah he's accomplished a
lot but what else does he got
yo yo [ __ ] yo yo what's good what's
good but yeah go babe we gotta see this
man oh yeah I know how to do it look at
that let's smooth I didn't know you
could stop there you know you stop here
and then you wait for it to come back
damn dude it feels good I had never felt
some powerful as a human being I'm
telling you aliens they're gonna come
yeah what's good first day huh all you
[ __ ]
thank you good you're not good you
nothing let's watch around the corner
what is that run the corner what what
let's say yo man says you'd like to try
I want to try okay so down and then you
put it on your elbow and then you flick
it up all right
I never even tried this this is scary Oh
in the war oh yes I say I'll win the bet
Joe Joe hits the floor it's a physical
extension on my body if I spin it too
hard it doesn't stay down
well holy crap oh what's in it can you
even see it
I need a better camera angle if I'm
gonna do this here we go
what's good what's good this feels like
a 2013 PvP video what's good what's good
what's good not my lighting my lighting
isn't good rocking the bit I never heard
of this rocking the baby is one of the
most famous of all the yo-yo tricks yo
yo man gets more requests for oh my god
yes I already know this one we call this
the clock like the pendulum do you know
this is how literally I got Marzia I'm
not even joking this first thing I did
when I landed in Italy I was like girl
what's good
I actually catfished her but then I
showed that yo yo all right listen
loop-de-loop whoa holy moly slowly no
that's impossible
the timing yes yes oh yeah
wrist and finger action that's what I'm
all about okay okay okay not good it's
not good it's not terrible evening it's
a bed in front of me if there wasn't
color oh oh what's up what's good what's
good I'm looping buddy it felt like I
did a good bit terrible I just realized
I got to do it straight how do I do it
straight okay that was once okay okay I
see it
ah damn it I'm sweating oh that was
clean dude I'm gonna get so much gamer
respect after this Jesus I could have
died I nearly could have died but it
would have been worth it I'm not scared
of the yo yo yo yo you're scared of me
yo you're scared of what I'll do to him
okay that was too loop-de-loops that was
three loop-de-loops
wrist and finger movement come on Felix
wrist and finger movement wrist and
finger movement yeah wrist and finger
movement oh oh oh I got the trick I
understand that was amazing dude once
you get it you get it once you got it
you got it I'm ready for the yo-yo
Championships you have to understand
that I'm also being watched that makes
me a little nervous you know if I wasn't
filming I could do all of these tricks
on the first time it was good flying
saucer what is that not only is the
flying saucer fun to watch but it also
adjusts the twist or the tension of the
yo-yo string see the yo-yo comes out
takes an angle in the sleeper position
continues until it's fly absolutely flat
and then you bring it back to the hand
now the reason it does this is unlike
the other tricks the yo-yo release is
not straight down it's to the side see
that yo yo man just plug it to the side
about what that's so cool boom back to
the palm of the hand now let's see how
we do this trick you take your
to the side seat right from the start
45-degree angle
now watch in a sleeper position the
yo-yo is cocked a little bit see it now
it's even continuing till it's
absolutely that's impossible that's
physically impossible in the strings
where you say we get up four to six
inches above the yo-yo that's insane
physics don't make sense anymore I'm
serious I can't even make it spin at
that angle oh my god I did okay so it is
possible oh oh no your man can do it
this okay I understand I'm fine
didn't even hurt have you seen that meme
where the guy shows off his pokemons on
Thanksgiving to his parents that feels
like what this is oh holy moly smoly
I did it almost this reminds me of a
time of one there you know when
everything wasn't discovered already you
can just do a bunch of cool [ __ ] you
know what I mean
oh wow this messed up the thread
completely oh god it's all ruined
do you know what I mean I understand the
mix of philosophy and yo-yo now it's all
coming together it's like my skating was
inventing it was like this new thing and
people are trying to test the limits of
what kind of thing you can do with it
yo-yo is in Venice
like what can you do for the yo-yo what
do we have now fortnight huh is that
what do we got thank you for that you
ruined my life
alright
did it what's good in honor of the yo-yo
man's completion of the oh my god he's
too strong did he ask for gold silver or
other material goods because
materialistic items will never make you
happy
suspenders is just a token of your
adaptation of the philosophy and it
shows that we don't need complex video
games with fancy graphics and smash 6
we don't need movies with epic cinema
CGI we just need simple yo-yo to be
happy happy
congratulations the advanced stage Jesus
what damn what there's a tiny baby in a
little cradle me
stop it huh the Eiffel Tower ah stop it
now you're just showing off oh my god
this is fired come on well I guess I
have a lot to learn oh my god those
effects Wow Oh the 80s was like when
they discover these new techniques and
they're like we have to use them we have
to use them all right it doesn't matter
if it looks out for who is the yo-yo man
I'm so confused what are you trying to
tell me yo yo huh what are you trying I
don't know if I should be doing this oh
[Applause]
okay all right you're just listing
reasons for me not to use the yo-yo now
you're ruining it for me yo Tom
instead of go Tom get it don't pop your
Bob Joe come on goddamn he's good
goddamn oh oh oh no stop stop it oh
don't do that
[Music]
well that was your man incredible I feel
like I learned a lot can't we can't we
if you enjoy this video smash like yo
your weak flora gang and I see you guys
not tomorrow in two days because I will
do nothing for a couple days because
that's life
you know what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course pixel
ings
is a creature collecting game I'm the
primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time 35 pixel
aims it's awesome deal with it deal with
it
[Music]
you